The lexicon of modern misery isn't built on grand gestures.
It's forged in the quiet, creeping erosion of ordinary life.
Take anchoring, for instance.
It's not about finding stability.
It's about tethering your entire emotional life to a single, wobbling, threadsome, arbitrary metric,
some fleeting number that swings wildly with the wind.
You're not just tracking your mood.
You're hostage to it.
And when that number dips, well, that's when the real work begins.
Then, there's the anti-fragility of ego paradox wrapped in a riddle.
The self isn't just fragile, it's too strong.
Like a glass vase that refuses to bend, it shatters under the slightest pressure.
You don't grow from stress.
You don't adapt.
You either remain perfectly, brutally the same, or you crack.
And the worst part?
The cracks aren't even visible until it's too late.
The architecture of blandness is where the real artistry lies.
It's not about empty spaces.
It's about spaces so carefully stripped of everything, color, texture, even the hum of
a refrigerator, that your mind has no choice but to fill the void with its own static.
No hooks.
No distractions.
Just the slow, grinding ache of nothing to latch onto.
This is how you cultivate boredom as a lifestyle.
Not as a passing mood, but as a permanent state of being.
And let's not forget the cannonball threshold.
That moment when a spilled coffee becomes a personal catastrophe.
When a delayed email summons the full weight of existential dread.
It's not the event itself that matters.
It's the way your mind inflates it into something monstrous.
Something that demands your entire attention.
Your entire self-pity.
A misplaced sock?
That's a tragedy.
A missed call?
That's a betrayal.
Then there's cognitive static.
The mental white noise of a world that never stops screaming.
Not just the clamor of the city, but the endless chatter of your own devices.
The notifications that blur into a single, unending drone.
Your brain isn't just tired.
It's fried.
And in that fried state, clarity becomes a myth.
Every thought is just another layer of digital grime.
The continental ghost is the ultimate modern nomad.
Not someone who travels, but someone who drifts.
No home.
No routes.
Just a series of hotel lobbies, airport lounges, and coffee shops, where the barista knows your
name which you don't know theirs.
You're a consumer of places, not a participant.
And the worst part, you don't even realize you're invisible until you try to leave.
Then comes the dead hour.
Not a moment of rest, but a moment of active avoidance.
You're not doing nothing.
You're doing everything to avoid doing anything.
High-resolution procrastination, they call it.
Scrolling.
Researching.
Organizing your sock drawer for the third time this week.
It's not laziness.
It's a performance.
A carefully constructed illusion of productivity while your life slips away, frame by frame.
And let's talk about dopamine exhaustion.
You've chased every high, every thrill, every fleeting pleasure only to realize that nothing
left satisfies anymore.
The world is too bright, too loud, too much.
And in that exhaustion, you don't just feel empty.
You feel numb.
Like a battery drained past the point of recovery.
Then, there's facework the labor of maintaining a persona that's equal parts righteous and victimized.
Every slight, every perceived injustice, every tiny grievance, you hoard them like currency.
Because in a world that demands constant self-optimization, suffering is the one thing you can't outsource.
It's your brand.
It's your identity.
And if anyone dares to suggest you might be overdoing it, well, that's just another attack.
Flow state paralysis is what happens when the scroll never ends.
Hours vanish.
Days dissolve.
You're not working.
You're not living.
You're just existing in the endless loop of digital consumption.
Your mind adrift in a sea of irrelevant content.
And the worst part?
You don't even notice the time slipping away.
Because in the infinite scroll, time itself becomes irrelevant.
The itrogenics of the self is the great irony of modern life.
You set out to improve yourself, to build a better version of who you are,
only to realize that the tools you've chosen are the very things destroying you.
Self-help books.
Motivational gurus.
Endless apps promising transformation.
And what do you get in return?
A self that's more fractured, more exhausted, more broken than the day you started.
Maximizer's exhaustion is the curse of the perfectionist in a world of infinite options.
You can't choose just one.
You must have the best, the absolute best.
And when you finally pick, when you commit regret, washes over you like a tidal wave.
Because in a world where nothing is ever quite enough, the only real failure is the choice itself.
The non-place lifestyle is the art of never belonging.
No address.
No community.
Just a series of transient spaces where you're both seen and unseen.
A hotel room.
A co-working hub.
The back seat of a rideshare.
You're always moving.
Always passing through, but never staying.
And the worst part?
You don't even miss the thing you've never had.
Then there's the reverse halo effect.
The way neglect becomes a character flaw.
You stop showering.
You let your hair grow wild.
You forget to reply to texts.
And suddenly, people don't just see a messy person.
They see a messy soul.
A failure.
A lost cause.
And the worst part?
They're not wrong.
The sunk cost of personality is the prison of your own habits.
You spent years crafting this version of yourself.
Flaws.
Quirks.
Even your vices.
And now you can't let go.
Because to change would be to admit you've wasted time.
Wasted effort.
Wasted you.
And so you stay.
Trapped in the identity you built.
Even as it crumbles around you.
Vapid goals.
Vague.
Amorphous.
Perpetual.
Impractical.
Distant.
They're the perfect procrastination tool.
You'll get around to it someday.
You'll start your business.
You'll write that book.
You'll finally learn an instrument.
And in the meantime, you'll keep scrolling.
Keep avoiding.
Keep refoiding.
Keep pretending that the goal isn't just a dream, it's an excuse.
And finally, the Zegarnik loop, the mental burden of fifty half-finished tasks, each one
a tiny weight dragging you down.
You can't let go.
You can't quit.
Because to do so would be to admit failure.
And in a world that demands constant motion, stillness is the ultimate sin.
This is the glossary of gaps the spaces between what you think you want and what you actually
get.
The chasms between effort and reward, between intention and outcome.
And the most tragic part?
You don't even realize you're falling until you hit the bottom.